وينضم الينا من مخيم نور شمس في طول كرم
مراسل الجزيره ليث جعار ليث ونحن نتابع
تقريرك يبدو ان شيئا ما
حدث
المشهد نعم نعم جيش جيش الاحتلال في هذه
اللحظات يستهدف الطواقم الصحفيه بصلي من
الرصاص بشكل مباشر هنا الزملاء الصحفيين
تعرضوا بشكل مباشر لاطلاق من قبل الاحتلال
لسيات من الرصاص باتجاهنا بشكل مباشر في
هذه المنطقه في محيط مخيم نور شمس في هذه
الاثناء الزملاء بشكل عام بعض الزملاء
تعرض
لاصابه نتيجه
لتط يعني وقوعه على الارض في هذه اللحظات
هنا احد الزملاء
الذين
ا اتمنى ان تكون
في ب بسلام بامان ليث وكما كنت تقول هناك
اصابات لصفوف الصحفي اعا الاتصال اليك لي
نعم نعم نعم الاحتلال في هذه الاثناء اطلق
صليات من الرصاص باتجاه الزملاء الصحفيين
بشكل مباشر في محاوله لاستهدافهم في هذه
المنطقه المتاخمه لمخيم نور شمس في هذه
اللحظات بالتزامن مع تواجد عشرات الاليات
العسكريه في محيط المخيم واطلاق ل وقوع
اشتباك مسلح في المنطقه الامر الذي ادى
لتوجيه الاحتلال لسيات من الرصاص باتجاه
الصحفيين بشكل عام بالرغم من انه قد شاهد
الزملاء خلال الساعات الفائته وتاكد بشكل
جلي من ان من تواجد في هذه المنطقه هم
صحفيين لكن رغم كل ذلك الاحتلال وبشكل
مباشر اطلق الرصاص صوب الزملاء الصحفيين
نشاهد في هذه الصوره الزملاء الصحفيين فور
اطلاق النار عليهم هنا احد الزملاء ايضا
تعرض لاصابه نتيجه وقوعه على الارض بعد
استهدافنا جميعا في هذه المنطقه بصلي من
الرصاص ليث يعني هذه اقتحامات شبه يوميه
هل سبق ان تعرضتم لمشهد
مشابه
نعم نعم يعني خلال التغطيات السابقه في
بعض الاحيان كنا نتعرض لاطلاق لاطلاق
مباشر من الرصاص لكن في هذه المره الامر
كان مختلف تماما حيث ان الاحتلال تعمد
بشكل واضح استهداف الصحفيين واطلاق صليات
من الرصاص باتجاههم في هذه
اللحظات ما طبيعه الاصابات التي تحدثت
عنها حتى الان
ليث
نتيجه نعم نعم هناك اصابه لزميل صحفي في
هذه المنطقه نتيجه لوقوعه على الارض فور
استهداف الرصاص او استهداف الجميع هنا
بالرصاص احد الزملاء وقع على الارض ادى ل
ردود في منطقه الركبه في هذه المنطقه
نتيجه لوقوعه على على الارض بعد وارتطام
بالحجاره في هذه المنطقه طيب ليس تقريبا
عدد الصحفيين المتواجدين في هذا المكان
وكم يبعد هذا المكان عن المخيم حيث قوات
الاحتلال نعم يعني عدد الصحفيين هنا ما
يزيد عن عره صحفيين لكن المكان يبعد عن
المخيم ما يقارب ال 500 متر يعني هناك
مسافه واضحه ما بين هذه المنطقه ووجود
وتحرك الصحفي
باتجاه المخيم لكن الجيش في هذه اللحظات
لا يزال مستمر في يعني يعني محاوله
استهداف على الاقل الزملاء الصحفيين ونحن
هنا نشاهد عبر الصوره عدد الصحفيين الذين
يتواجدون في هذه المنطقه حيث ان الاحتلال
استهدفهم جميعا بشكل مباشر بالرغم من انه
يعلم بانهم هنا من او من يتواجد في هذه
المنطقه هم صحفيين نعم شكرا جزيلا ليث
الحمد لله على سلامتكم واتمنى ان تكون في
امان وسنعود
اليك في وقت لاحق لمواصله هذه التغطيه